the waves of immigration that have
freshened refreshed America you can see
it you can see this wave of Hispanic
immigration refresh in America just as
the European immigrations of the 20th
century refreshed America we have such a
tremendous capacity to take people in
and make them American the American
system is so so strong that it is an
easy it it changes it reacts but it also
in it reshapes itself a little bit but
it's so encompass into a certain extent
so welcoming if you look at the way
Americans feel despite the debate about
immigration these days if you look at
about the way Americans feel about
bringing people in and being an American
the view is if you come here and want to
be an American and act like an American
you are an American that is certainly
not the view in large parts of the world
and in many many Western countries and
in the public that's not the view of the
public's of mini rally
you